hi my name is avinash and i'm the author
of
the books web analytics 2.0 and web
analytics scenario day i'm very excited
to present this webinar about
web analytics to all of you um
in this uh particular video i want to
cover the the incredible opportunity
that exists in using data online in
solving key business problems as well as
outline for you some of the more
specific things that you can do once you
do start using web analytics and sort of
aspirationally all of the other more
wonderful things that are over the
horizon that you'll be able to take
advantage of once you start creating a
truly data-driven business
now why would you want to do web
analytics a lot of people ask me this
question and honestly it surprises me
because
if you're not
wanting deeply profoundly desiring to be
data-driven
then
really there is no honest way to survive
in the world that we live in today as
all different channels come together and
online continues to dominate growth for
companies and growth for non-profits as
a matter of fact but let me crystallize
why you should invest in web analytics
in a very simple way when you take out
an ad in a magazine and try and measure
success in this case an ad for chevy
malibu all of the measures for success
are interpretive or proxy driven for
example you take out an ad in the time
magazine and the best proxy you have for
measuring success is the number of
subscribers the magazine has you have
absolutely no idea how many people might
have opened the magazine how many people
might have bothered to even see a
gorgeous little ad
and and much less you would know how
many people then went to a dealership
and might have purchased the product
that you're selling in this magazine ad
but if you think about it when you take
out that exact same ad in this case on
google or yahoo or microsoft or aol or
or any other property in the world the
ad that shows up right here at the very
top it does not require you to use your
faith to measure success you can use
data to measure success because you can
measure exactly how many people saw the
ad you can measure how many people
clicked on the ad how many people
interacted with the ad and finally if
people do come to your website as a
result of this ad you're able to measure
how many people customize the car set up
a appointment at the dealership
downloaded a brochure and and all of the
outcomes that are available for that
single ad that you took so the
measurement of success rather than being
interpretive and proxy driven is direct
it is specific and it is scalable and i
cannot think of a better more powerful
and profound reason for you to use web
analytics than that it moves you away
from making business decision based on
faith and what you be
even to shifting to using data and
bringing a massive amount of
accountability to the processes that
you're executing for your business